visita sorpresa de bolodimir selens que
los soldados de primera línea en la
ciudad oriental de escenario de algunos
de los combates más encarnizados de las
últimas semanas en Ucrania el presidente
alabó la resistencia de los residentes
De esta zona intentó reforzar la moral
de sus militares afirmando que al dunbas
representa un escudo para el resto del
país
están defendiendo a toda Ucrania Porque
después del hacer lo mismo en otras
ciudades ucranianas ya que quieren
borrar todo lo relacionado con Ucrania
estoy 100% seguro de eso
que ustedes llevan la defensa de toda
Ucrania sobre sus hombros no solo la
defensa del donbas neto
otro presidente felicitando a sus tropas
Pero esta vez del lado ruso Vladimir
Putin entregó premios a los líderes
separatistas de los cuatro territorios
ucranianos anexados en septiembre pero
admitió que Rusia se enfrenta a una
situación extremadamente difícil en
estas regiones cada país de hecho cada
persona supera algunas dificultades A lo
largo del camino pero hoy en día de
hecho van acompañadas de dificultades
particulares y en la vanguardia de la
resolución de las tareas más complejas
responsables y peligrosas están sin
falta nuestros soldados
estas ceremonia se produce un día
después de la primera visita en varios
años de Vladimir Putin a su vecino de la
Luz con el objetivo de mantener
conversaciones con su líder Alexander
lucasenco que permitió a las tropas
rusas iniciar su intervención militar en
Ucrania desde su territorio en febrero
putina negó planes para absorber velarús
Pero los dos ex aliados soviéticos
prometieron una cooperación militar más
estrecha en el futuro